given that the chinese central brent
bank is printing when in order to keep
it devalued to other foreign currencies
especially relative to the dollar a
question that may have jumped into your
brain is is this causing
inflation
and when i talk about inflation i'm
talking about price inflation is it
making a basket of goods in china more
expensive and the other type of
inflation that the word inflation is
sometimes referring to is monetary
inflation that by definition is
increasing they are definitely
increasing the money supply but is it
making the price of goods and services
in china more expensive and to answer
that question i have this article here
from the new york times written by keith
bradsher early january 2011 and he
writes
in china consumer prices were 5.1
percent higher in november than a year
earlier remember in the us we try to
target inflation to be between one and
three percent so the official government
data so this is according to official
government data they they admit that
their inflation is at 5.1 percent but
the next sentence is even more
interesting and many economists say the
official figures actually understate
actually understate the rate of
inflation which might in reality be
twice as high and there's tons of ways
to kind of engineer the actual inflation
depending on what the basket of goods is
and how you adjust for things
now though that cheap currency policy
seems to be reaching its limits the
extra renminbi and this is a big point
of confusion when people talk about the
currency in china the renminbi is the
name of is is the name of the currency
while the when is kind of when someone
talks about hey i gave you five when or
you owe me five when something like they
wouldn't say you owe me five renminbi
and a good analogy is when you talk
about if you go to if you go to great
britain and you buy something they'll
say oh it'll be five pounds so in great
britain five pounds is what they say
when you're actually buying something
but the name of the currency is called
the sterling
is called the sterling it's kind of like
if people call the dollar u.s legal
tender that's the equivalent of renminbi
while you win would be like the dollar
so five pounds it's called the sterling
so the similar analogy five u.n
they call that the renminbi
ren
min b so they're saying the extra
renminbi are feeding inflation that is
starting to undermine exporters price
competitiveness competitiveness just as
a stronger renminbi would do if beijing
was not intervening to begin with so the
whole reason why they're printing this
money is to keep the currency devalued
but that's making things more expensive
in terms of when so in the end that's
kind of counteracting some of this cheap
currency policy it's making their
exports more expensive
money supply figures for december which
the central bank released on tuesday
showed that cash and bank deposits were
increasing at a rate twice as fast as
even china's soaring economy so if you
increase the money supply roughly in
line with the growth in the economy then
you wouldn't experience too much
inflation but they're increasing it
twice as fast
ever more renminbi are available to buy
goods and services so you see they're
clearly doing that to try to keep their
currency devalued but they're reaching
kind of a it seems kind of a breaking
point where they won't be able to do it
as aggressively
going forward